being Cairo would be we all fell in love
with pixels in the last film and we
wanted to find a unique and interesting
way to take his powers for the going of
the extraction the mansion is imploding
so I try to get everybody out
we use some of the most sophisticated
filming technology in creating this very
very elaborate sequence we use the
Phantom for the slow motion the phantom
camera runs 3,000 frames per second so
it can freeze real time and to put that
into perspective something that happens
in just a blink of an eye turns into
about 15 seconds in order to get our
timing right we're hoping to move our
camera at close to 90 miles per hour as
it goes through the explosion visual
effects wise there's so many more
elements now everything's froze and
they're flying through the air the real
challenges their safety is its landing
in close proximity to each other the
guy's been rehearsin for the most of the
week and I think we're ready to go here
we go three two one go
I'm awful cigars I'm here now he always
had four followers like the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse